what's up everyone it's time for another
YouTube meet up here in Toronto I did
one last month it was super successful
really proud of the work that Toronto
and city youtubers are doing so I
thought we put on another one this one
we're going to talk about how to make
money on YouTube going to share some
wisdom and expertise give some shoutouts
and then also do some channel reviews
and videos and help each other out get
some feedback potluck style for three
hours tonight alex is off at two
birthday parties Nina's off at something
else that she's going to come later so
I'm setting up solo today hopefully it
goes well and I'm going to be including
some other youtubers on this video from
Toronto to share their advice on how to
make money so i'm going to set up and
stay tuned
hello this is energy from Toronto real n
and j are sweet so the tip today is how
to monetize your youtube channel the
district to monetize YouTube channel is
to first have good content to be able to
increase the audience and then you can
worry about on as a new channel that's
what are there today hey guys david here
and my youtube tip tip on monetization
is just think outside the box so a lot
of people think about just making money
through ads on YouTube but sponsorships
friend deals and even selling
merchandise is a great way to make money
on youtube as well I like to talk about
the 4 p's persistence passion and
patience and playlist just a great
emotional playlist that a great value
and do what you love that's about it
really keep creating content so don't
let yes there's affiliate links and
they're sponsorships but don't let that
prevent you from making that video
because when you're inspired don't wait
for the affiliate link just create the
video and trust that the inspiration
will just keep coming and as you build
your channel you're building your brand
you're building your brand as you build
your content in your channel so it
becomes easy to just connect the dots
and build that mosaic that
is your content curation thanks believe
nation my advice is if you want to lead
people back to you a product or service
that you wats yuh tink is a great place
to do it so for example I have an online
course and my youtube videos I'm just
picking different tips that I have sir
on my youtube videos on the dummy videos
and my horrible is to offer tips getting
from interested in what I'm saying and
in SEO and then people back to my demo
course so great
we monetize fun and Demi quick so
realize we only had five tips from the
youtubers that came out so I'm going to
add two of my own tips on how you can
make money through your YouTube channel
so rule number six is look at the
AdWords tool if you're trying to make
money from advertising on YouTube it
really is about if you're in the right
niche so YouTube will pay you based on
how many thousands of views you get on
your channel it's called CPM so it might
be I think the average is like 150 to
250 CPM so for every thousand people
that view your video you will make a
dollar 50 to 250 it's somewhere in there
but there's a big range of where that
can go so a lot of my videos will make
more because I'm in the business niche
if I did videos on insurance as an
example that's a really high-paying
category where I might be able to make
thirty forty fifty dollars CPM per
thousand views instead of a dollar fifty
or two dots and fifty cents so really
depends on your niche and a cool tool to
use is the AdWords tool this is a free
tool that Google puts out and it's more
for their Google side of things in the
search results than YouTube but it
usually carries over so you can type in
different keywords and see which ones
are more high pain and then create
content around that I would just give
you the caveat that you still need to
create content that you care about if I
turn this channel into always talking
about insurance because it pays me
really well you guys are tuned out
because it's not interesting right it
doesn't doesn't float the boat but you
don't care about insurance right that's
probably why it's so high pain because
it's hard for them to get good views on
videos and so I would look at using that
AdWords tool to help you fix your titles
to help you maybe pick some of the
topics to help you round out your tags
in the description as long as it's
really relevant to your niche and it may
give you ideas to do just make sure that
you you are feeling the videos that
you're making and you're not just doing
it trying to make money and number seven
is push the brands that you work with
brand deals are a big thing everybody
wants to make brand deals it's one of
the fastest way that I've grown my
channels partner up with different
brands and getting paid to create
content and help give them exposure and
promotion
what I almost always find is the brand
doesn't really know what they're doing
on YouTube I've always had to push a
brain in a greater direction so they
almost always come to me either the
brand directly or an APC that they're
working with and they have a plan and
it's usually a small plan like hey we
want you to make one video on this topic
is that something to be of interest and
usually their idea is just okay mostly
because the brains and the agencies
don't have a lot of YouTube experience
and so they just see a big market but
they don't really know how to
effectively communicate with them and so
when I first started I thought these
guys were the experts I you know I need
to learn from these guys but I really
discovered and working with them that
they don't know what they're doing and
you need to guide them to something that
will work for you and for your audience
it's how you interact with your arms may
be different than me with my ions and
someone else with their audience and so
I almost always take the project that
they initially give me and modify it to
fit what works my audience and then push
it to a bigger deal where one video
won't really have a big impact for the
community but if we do it consistently
we're doing it for a year a video a
month every every month for a year that
can help really build a lot of goodwill
towards your brain so I'll almost always
try to push for a longer term engagement
after pushing around that first things
that came to me for so I find you really
have to do that with brands and they
appreciate it because again they don't
know what they're doing they need
something to educate them on YouTube and
it's also how you can charge a higher
more premium price because you're giving
them knowledge you're giving them
strategy much more than just giving them
an audience
all right it is coming up on 1030 just
finished up we gotta pack up Nina has
already started there she is cleaning up
Nina brought this awesome stir fry we
were supposed to bring food and I was
gonna make anything so I did I had to
ask Nina like so I'm gonna buy something
or what do you want to do is like no I'm
gonna make fun for everybody just make
sure you bring my spoon back was the
message so thank you guys for watching
thank you for joining another series
here the YouTube meetups in Toronto
hopefully you're doing something to
contribute back to your local community
and for those of you Torontonians I look
forward seeing of the next one and for
those of you aren't in Toronto come to
toronto for the next YouTube meet up and
let's talk about your channel in your
business i'm super pump thank you guys
so much for watching continue to believe
and we'll see you soon see how low I
have to get to match Nina okay